hey youtubers is Charlie so they finally
revealed supergirls official costume so
I wanted to do my first Supergirl bonus
video I'm gonna do weekly episode videos
whenever the show gets here but they're
probably not gonna screen the pilot till
comic-con and it's not gonna debut till
the fall so it's still a long ways off
we do know a lot about the cast already
but I wanted to do a comic book
explainer for her history there's been a
lot of different versions of Supergirl
and just like the flash TV show is
combining Wally West and Barry Allen's
runs
I think the Supergirl is gonna combine a
lot of aspects for all the different
super girls including the Man of Steel
movie just because of her Kryptonian
heritage so I'll try to explain all that
just to talk about the costume for a
minute so the the TV show is being made
by the same people that make arrow the
flash the flash spin-off so the same
person that designed Oliver Queen's
costume and Barry Allen's designed this
one so the color scheme is very much in
the end of tone of those costumes but it
also flows a lot from Henry Cavill suit
from Man of Steel and just like on the
flash this is the first version of her
costume so it'll probably evolve over
time just like they've said that the
flash costume is gonna evolve over time
so this is just Supergirl 1.0 so let's
talk about supergirls origin story in
the comics there there's two real big
origin stories that I'm gonna go with
because on the show she's gonna be Lynda
Danvers but the Lynda Danvers Supergirl
is different from the Kara zor-el
Supergirl and her name is Kara zor-el
Lynda Danvers is gonna be the alias she
uses just like Superman uses Clark Kent
everybody high five for complicated
comic-book backstories most of you ply
know the basics Supergirl is Superman's
Kryptonian cousin there been a lot of
different people to use the name
Supergirl most people who know about
Lynda Danvers and Kara zor-el but Power
Girl is also an alternate reality
version of Supergirl if you haven't read
the comics don't worry it doesn't matter
Power Girl why not gonna exist on the TV
show it's all thanks to the DC
multiverse which which at times they've
collapsed and expanded so the TV show
gonna streamline all this stuff make it
way simpler to follow so let's start
with the Kara zor-el Supergirl she's the
first one to appear in the comics DC
naturally wanted a female version of
their most popular character Batman did
the exact same thing later it makes
sense you have a super popular character
you want a female version of them she
was created by Otto binder and alp
lastino
in 1959 her first issue was Action
Comics number two
fifty-two which is interesting because
that's the same issue that metallo
debuted the John Corben metallo and also
interesting sidenote Otto binder the
writer that story also wrote the short
story I Robot that inspired Isaac
Asimov's I Robot short stories that came
much much later Joss Whedon even said
that the Otto binder short story heavily
influenced his take on the vision in age
of Ultron so lots of meta Marvel DC
Comics DNA crossing over and all of you
just heard the name metallo and you're
like wait does that mean that he's gonna
be on the TV show they haven't confirmed
that hank henshaw is the only villain
that we know is gonna appear in the
pilot i'll explain him later because he
has a different origin story that
doesn't really crossover with Supergirl
so they're gonna have to change a lot of
things so originally Kara zor-el was
from Argo city her home was separated
from the planet Krypton when it exploded
in her father's arel turned it into this
this self-contained floating city in
space when an asteroid threatened to
destroy it he sent her into space just
like Superman's father sent him into
space and because they had known that
Superman was on earth that's where they
sent her so that she could live with one
of her kind so one day Superman's
working in his office and he sees a
spaceship crash goes sees that it's a
Kryptonian inside agrees to train her
gives her the fake name Linda Lee
censored to Midvale to live and she ends
the short story just being like super
pumped about getting to go on adventures
with Superman and being a superhero so a
pretty simple story or already that
sounds just like a pilot the TV show is
gonna change some things about this
because she's gonna use the alias Linda
Danvers and that's like a completely
different character in the comics so
here's an explainer on on who that Linda
Danvers Supergirl is she's also known as
the matrix Supergirl
so what happened is is is a crisis on
Infinite Earths killed the Kara zor-el
Supergirl she died during that so DC had
to get a little timey wimey with the way
it explained the backstory of the new
Supergirl that appeared the Linda
Danvers Supergirl started out as the
matrix Supergirl also a different
character I know already this is super
confusing so we have to explain matrix
first the matrix Supergirl is from an
alternate reality pocket universe in
that reality Superman doesn't exist
anymore
but Lex Luthor who is a good person he's
not evil yet wants to fight Zod and
Faora who are trying to take over the
earth so he Korea
this protoplasmic matrix character they
can shape-shift and has some of the
abilities of Superman matrix fights Zod
but isn't able to beat him
selects sends it to the main DC Universe
where Superman is still alive gets
Superman to come back and help defeat
Zod but their earth is destroyed the
pocket universe earth is destroyed so
she goes back to the main universe to
live forever that's the story of how
matrix ended up in the main DC
continuity it's like a really weird
complicated backstory
Linda Danvers was originally just a
regular human girl she became super girl
when she sustained life-threatening
injuries and the matrix tried to heal
her by merging with her so she became
the Linda Danvers Supergirl much much
later in the comics the Linda Danvers
Supergirl ended up meeting the Kara
zor-el Supergirl who DC had brought back
into the continuity and then they
coexisted so there were like two super
girls living in the DC Universe but
obviously the TV show is gonna change
that they're gonna it's gonna like
combine those two characters and
there'll be one Supergirl
it's just like the flash TV show
combines wally west stories and Barry
Allen stories in the name of sanity what
they're probably gonna do is explain her
TV backstory saying she was rocketed
from Krypton just like Superman was and
the Man of Steel movie because of
timey-wimey space reasons she didn't
land on her till much later after
Superman Superman is supposed to have a
cameo in the pilot really don't know how
he's gonna appear he might just appear
as Clark Kent don't have any
confirmation on that so so we'll just
wait to see official footage they'll
probably say she was found by the
Danvers family and had a similar
upbringing to what Superman had with the
Kent's in the comics Linda Danvers
father is a police officer so already
you can kind of see how that might build
into some of the procedural aspects of
the show just like like a Joe West type
character the impetus of the show is
gonna be Kara or you know Linda however
you want to think about her learning to
fight crime while leading a normal life
doing like the Clark Kent Superman thing
so her father being a Joe West
detective type character totally makes
sense like I said Supergirl is being
made by the same people that make the
flash so already you could see a lot of
the same DNA in the shows you know Barry
Allen works at the police station
Kara's gonna be working for a cat grant
like the cat grant and the DC comics so
it'll be a little bit different what she
does during the day but at night she'll
be fighting crime just like the flash
does CBS has been really upfront about
how the show is going to be
more of a procedural so think of
Supergirl as being like the flash if it
played out more like a CSI show but the
tone is gonna be very much like the
flash very hopeful very bouncy daylight
as opposed to arrow is really dark
gritty nighttime you know HBO wire take
there's a couple things they have
confirmed about the pilot Jimmy Olsen's
been cast he's gonna be her love
interest
they'll probably both work it at Catco
that's the name of the company that cat
grant owns hank henshaw is the main
villain they've cast her Kryptonian
mother I don't really know how they're
gonna deal with that she's not gonna
have a fortress of solitude like
Superman has so so we'll see what that
looks like and they've also cast a
sister for her like a Danvers sister in
real life just to explain hank henshaw
is back story in the comics cyborg
superman is a great character a great
villain of Superman's but I think
they're gonna change a few small things
about his backstory just to make it work
with the Supergirl character his story
is kind of funny it plays out a lot like
Fantastic Four's origin story he's a
NASA astronaut he and his wife go into
space to study solar radiation for Lex
Corp they get hit by a solar flare
almost died returned to Earth but
they're like they're heavily modified by
this crazy radiation Superman tries to
save them is able to save hank henshaw
wife but he can't save hank henshaw
his mind gets uploaded into the Lex Corp
database and he continues living in
digital form eventually he reveals
himself to his wife he's like I didn't
die I'm alive I'm just you know in this
machine she goes crazy jumps out a
window Hank Henshaw blames Superman and
vows revenge Superman goes on to battle
with him eventually Hank Henshaw
digitally beams himself into Superman's
Kryptonian spaceship and uses it to
escape into orbit while he's traveling
through space he uses Superman's DNA
that this left inside the spaceship to
create a cyborg body for himself thus he
becomes cyborg superman already you can
see they're gonna simplify some things
about this for the TV show like III
don't think we're gonna see cyborg
superman I do think that we'll see hank
henshaw die I think we'll see his wife
die if he's gonna be the villain they
they have to put him at odds with
Supergirl so something will probably
happen to him and his family Supergirl
will try to save him she'll fail he'll
blame her and and thus he'll become her
villain here's my big question for you
guys
do you want to see cyborg superman
become the main villain the season 1 or
do you think it'll be like the flash
we're like the main villain of the pilot
dies and then they bring in a bunch of
other characters cyborg superman just
feels like a really big character so
what they might do is kill him at the
end of the pilot and then bring him back
later in the series as cyborg Superman
he might just pop up as a ghost in the
machine throughout the series one of the
really big problems with Supergirl
stories is that she shares so many
characters with Superman that it's hard
to pick and choose who gets to be in the
movies and who the TV shows get to use I
think DC's cutting them a break and let
him use some Superman characters but
like Lex Luthor for instance probably
not gonna be on the TV show probably
only gonna be in the film's Brainiac
though I think they can totally do
Brainiac if the flash TV show can do
korilla Grodd I think that the Supergirl
show can do Brainiac that means they
could also do bottle city of Kandor just
because Brainiac Kandor kind of go hand
in hand so I'm gonna be doing tons more
bonus videos for Supergirl like my
favorite stories in the comics favorite
villains all kinds of stuff so be sure
to subscribe to get all that stuff feel
free to leave requests too
it took us a while to figure out what
was going on with the flash so I'm
really excited hopefully I'll get a
chance to see the pilot at Comic Con if
you guys are comic-con - you have a
pretty good shot at seeing it well you
guys wait for that stuff you can click
here to learn about how the flash deals
with time travel and the Speed Force and
you can click here to learn about Batman
death in the family thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
now let's all do the thing
you